[Music]
have you heard of levers or lever
systems
leverage is a concept commonly covered
in physics and biomechanics courses but
even if you don't know the specific
mathematical formulas you know the way
leverage works
force is applied to an arm called a
lever in conjunction with a fixed point
called a fulcrum
lever systems have been used throughout
history to gain a mechanical advantage
and enhance the power or speed of a
movement
such as to move heavy objects with a
wheelbarrow or is used in a tool like a
pry bar a bottle opener or the ore of a
boat
this concept of leverage is also used in
a teeter-totter or seesaw at a child's
playground or by skateboarders in some
of their moves
our joints and their movements are also
examples of leveraged systems
here the bones serve as the levers
they are the elongated and inflexible
parts of the system that move around a
joint which is the fixed point or
fulcrum
to get movement in the leverage system
the effort applied to one end of the
liver has to overcome the resistance or
load at the other end
in the body the effort is the force
generated by muscle activity
since bones and joints can't move
themselves
the resistance is the weight of the body
part distal to the fulcrum and any added
weight on that body part like a dumbbell
in your hand or a heavy box that you're
carrying
there are different types of levers
called first second and third class
systems so the pattern is not always as
simple as in a seesaw
but that's an easy example to illustrate
the point
if we use the elbow as an example
the hinge-like joint between the humerus
and the ulna is the fulcrum
the effort or force needed to flex the
elbow that means to bend it is provided
by some anterior muscles of the upper
arm proximal to the elbow
the resistance or load the effort must
overcome to achieve movement is the
weight of the forearm and hand as well
as anything in the hand
so the reason weight lifting builds
muscles is that we increase the
resistance or load by putting a dumbbell
in our hand which means that the effort
or force provided by the muscle must
also increase if the load is to be moved
this increased weight in the liver
system strengthens and builds up the
muscle
and by the way we don't add more muscle
cells
we simply increase the number of protein
strands called myofilaments within the
existing muscle cells
which in turn adds bulk to and
strengthens the muscle
that's why a good diet with plenty of
protein is also essential to build
muscle tissue
now let's get more specific and use some
hardware models to help illustrate how
interrelated the structure of a joint is
with its specific functions
there are essentially six main types of
joints based on the shapes of
articulating bones and as a result of
that anatomy the range of motion they
allow
these joint types and their motions vary
from simple gliding movements of flat
surfaces against each other
to angular movements like at the elbow
where the distance between the bones
changes through a range of motion
as well as other elbow joint actions
like rotation
there are six main categories of freely
movable synovial joints based on their
structure
presented here to some degree from
simple to complex in their movements
plane or planar joints are articulations
in which a pair of relatively flat bone
surfaces simply slide against each other
like when using a sanding block against
a wooden surface
since the articulating surfaces never
leave each other they just slide back
and forth
these joints don't allow as much
movement as many other joint types but
they're still diarthrotic synovial
joints
we'll see these types of planar joints
between the tarsal bones in the ankle
and foot
and between the carpal bones of the
wrist
pivot or rotational joints work like a
trailer hitch
like planar joints the surfaces don't
really leave each other so much as one
surface rotates inside a circular or
semicircular surface made by the other
bone
for this reason they're known as
monoaxial joints since movement is in a
single plane
we'll see this type of articulation at
the part of the elbow joint where the
radius joins the humerus allowing us to
rotate our forearm palm up and palm down
we'll also see a pivot joint between the
first two vertebrae of the neck
allowing us to rotate our head left and
right we've already mentioned hinge
joints in which the articulating bones
physically resemble a door or cabinet
hinge
these are also mono axial joints that
allow movement in a single plane
so only in two directions like back and
forth similar to the way a door moves
besides the hinge joint between the
humerus and ulna at the elbow the knees
are hinged joints as are the
interphalangeal joints between bones and
the fingers which are called phalanges
condyloid or ellipsoidal joints allow a
joystick-like movement between a concave
oval surface
and a matching convex oval surface
a good example of that is between the
radius of the forearm and a couple of
the carpal bones of the wrist
or between the metacarpals of the palm
of the hand and the proximal phalanges
of the fingers
the corresponding oval ends of the bones
nest in each other like spoons in a
drawer
these condyloid or ellipsoidal joints
you'll hear both terms used in
musculoskeletal anatomy are biaxial
joints because the movement occurs in
two planes
saddle joints are relatively rare
articulations in which one bone
resembles a saddle and the other a rider
in that saddle
the best example of this is where the
base of the thumb meets the wrist this
is where the metacarpal bone in the
thumb side of the palm joins the lateral
most carpel of the wrist called the
trapezium due to its shape
saddle joints are biaxial as they allow
movement in more than one direction
this is one reason the thumb is such a
special feature of primates
this prehensile grasping thumb allows
that grasping motion characteristic of
primate hands like ours
the last but certainly not the least
category of synovial joints by structure
are ball and socket joints these are
what are known as multi-axial joints
because they allow movement in all three
dimensions
as in an x-axis y-axis and z-axis
these joints allow the greatest range of
motion
a complexity of movement that is only
possible at our shoulder and hip joints
the ball and socket joints in the human
body
hardware models are good schematic
representations of the six main types of
joints by structure
but i use another model in the classroom
to illustrate the main types of movement
possible at a joint
take a pencil and put it on a flat
surface like a piece of blank paper if
you wish
if you don't feel like getting up but
hey this is a course about movement
you can use your index finger on one
hand as a substitute for the pencil and
use the palm of your other hand to
represent the flat plane
the spot where your pencil or finger is
touching the plane
represents the joint which in the
leverage system was the fulcrum the
place where the two bones meet
gliding movements would be represented
by sliding your pencil or finger on that
flat surface like making a little x or a
t
without altering the angle between the
tip of the pencil or your finger and
that flat surface
to simulate rotational movement spin the
pencil or your finger against the flat
plane
this is how rotational joints work
one bone rotates against the other but
the angle between the bones doesn't
change they stay in the same plane
and the movement is said to be monoaxial
since the rotation is occurring along
that single plane
now angular motions work like a switch
or a joystick
the angle between the two participating
bones changes so keep the pencil or your
finger against the flat surface but
moving move it back and forth or right
to left like flipping a switch or
pulling a lever
hinge joints work like this but in
either a simple forward and back pattern
or a right to left pattern not in both
of those planes
so they're monoaxial joints however
condyloid joints have multiple
directions for their angular movements
so are biaxial joints with two planes of
movement like a joystick that moves back
and forth as well as side to side
now ball and socket joints move in
multiple directions and can rotate as
well
as we'll see when discussing the
shoulder and the hip
these type of joints move in all three
dimensions
sometimes the term circumduction is used
for movement in an arc like standing
with your shoulder toward a chalkboard
and then drawing a large circle on the
board
but really when you think about it
that's just an ever-changing series of
angular movements in a sequence
ball and socket joints can do even more
than that they combine these
multi-directional angular movements with
rotational movements as well
thus picking up all three axes or
dimensions
so are called multi-axial joints
now let's cover the terminology for
these forward and back and side to side
movements
using more specific language
along with some particular joints as
examples of places where these movements
occur
as with the terms forward and back these
motions often come in pairs
much like we saw with directional term
opposites like anterior and posterior or
proximal and distal
we'll also need to bring back standard
anatomical position
which has the spine and limbs straight
since these straight lines of anatomical
position are also the standard reference
positions of joints from which movements
are made
let's start with flexion and extension
which are easy to understand in limbs
flexion is bending such as at the elbow
or knee and extension returns us to
anatomical position
with regard to the joints within limbs
flexion always decreases the angle
between the articulating bones so i'm
flexing at the elbow at the wrist and at
the fingers since all these angles
decrease
extension increases the angle between
the articulating bones bringing us back
to anatomical position
notice that in a sense our knees and
elbows are on backward
in that during flexion at the elbow the
direction of movement is anterior while
it's posterior at the knee
this is due to the rotation that occurs
in the lower limb during the development
of vertebrates that is animals with a
backbone which we'll talk about more
with the lower limb
however this angular movement is similar
at the ball and socket joints of the
shoulder and hip where forward is
flexion in both
i tell my students to remember f and f
forward equals flexion at ball and
socket joints an extension
is a posterior movement restoring us to
standard anatomical position regardless
of upper or lower limb
but once you're within the limb flexion
always decreases the angle of the two
bones at the joint
now flexion of the spine is a forward
bend whether only at the neck or whether
touching your toes
but we can also do a side bend or move
the ear towards the shoulder which is
specifically called lateral flexion of
the spine
extension is returning to a straight
spine as an anatomical position
sometimes the term hyperextension is
used for a movement beyond anatomical
position
but that depends on the source some
books will reserve hyperextension only
for positions that go beyond the normal
range of motion like people who can
slightly hyper extend at their elbows
there's no absolute standard there for
instance it's pretty common to call
looking up at the ceiling or up at the
stars hyper extension of the neck
while we use extension of the wrist for
the complete range of motion possible
there beyond anatomical position
now some sources even use the term
extension for any movement in the
opposite direction of flexion
and reserve hyperextension for
pathological states maybe following an
injury
another angular movement pair are
abduction and adduction which are
possible at ball and socket joints but
also at condyloid joints like the wrist
and the knuckle joints between the
fingers and palms
in anatomy and physiology especially in
the musculoskeletal courses and clinical
courses my physical therapy students
take
you'll hear these said as a b duction
and a deduction
since it's often hard to hear the
difference in those terms especially
when coming out of the mouth of a fast
speaker like me
abduction takes the body part away from
the midline and a deduction brings it
back towards the midline of the body
those words are helpful since if someone
is abducted they are taken away while
adduction adds the body part back to the
midline
i should also mention that some body
parts can have their own midline for
abduction and adduction
for example with regard to the hands the
middle finger is the axis for abduction
and adduction with reference to
movements of the fingers
now in class this is when i usually get
to give my students the middle finger
and tell them it's not often we teachers
get to do that to the class that always
gets a laugh
in the special term horizontal abduction
is used for taking an outstretched upper
limb from pointing straight ahead out to
the side
also remember that abduction and
adduction are not possible at the hinge
joints of the elbow or knee since those
are monoaxial joints and move in only an
anterior and posterior direction related
to anatomical position
in the arc-like movement called
circumduction which only happens at ball
and socket joints
we're really just combining a series of
angular motions we start that circuit
with flexion
and then we gradually abduct away from
the body and then we move into extension
until we finally adduct back toward the
body returning us to anatomical position
that's different from rotational
movements such as happen at pivot joints
so let's look at true rotational
movements
there's a pivot joint between our first
and second vertebra of the spine that
looks and functions like a trailer hitch
the second cervical vertebra has a
projection that sticks up in the first
cervical vertebra with the skull on top
of it
rotates around that projection giving us
a much greater side to side range of
motion of our head than at other places
in the spine
rotational movement also happens at the
elbow specifically at the part of the
elbow joint between the radius and the
humerus
the elbow is quite a complex joint since
three bones articulate there
the humerus of the upper arm articulates
with both the radius and ulna of the
forearm
the joint between the ulna and the
humerus is the hinge joint we've spoken
of while the one between the radius and
the humerus is a pivot joint
perhaps because our upper limbs are so
important to our daily lives there's a
special name given to the rotational
movement between the humerus and the
radius
supination is the term for palm forward
like an anatomical position
and pronation is the opposite term for
when the palm is turned backward or
should i say posteriorly
i teach my students this memory trick
you could hold a bowl of soup in a
supinated hand but if you turn that hand
over you're prone to drop the soup
remember as was mentioned in the first
lesson
supine and prone are also used for
positions on a surgical table a gurney
or on the floor at a crime scene
supine is belly up and prone is face
down and while those aren't movements
they are deviations from anatomical
position
and come from the same word roots as
supination and pronation of the elbow
as i pronate and supinate you really see
the movement at the wrist and hand
but it's actually happening at the elbow
now we'll cover all these specifics of
the joints when we get to their section
of the course
and i'll remind you of this terminology
then as well
other rotational movements happen at
ball and socket joints
in the lower limbs inward internal or
medial rotation is performed
when pointing the toes toward the
midline
while lateral outward or external
rotation is the act of pointing the toes
out toward the sides
the knee really can't do that kind of
rotation that action is happening at the
ball and socket joint of the hip
same with the shoulder moving my forearm
and hand towards my body is inward or
medial rotation while swinging my
forearm and hand out to the side
is lateral or outward rotation
both are happening at the shoulder joint
but it's easiest to see with a flexed
elbow to avoid confusing or mistaking
that action with supination and
pronation at the elbow
now just as pronation and supination are
particular to the elbow
some other movements are specific to
only a selected joint
there's a special set of movements of
the foot known as inversion and eversion
inversion refers to directing the sole
of the foot toward the midline while
everting the foot directs the sole of
the foot outward away from the body
these are often said to happen at the
ankle but as we'll see later these
movements actually happen within the
foot itself not between the leg and foot
at the ankle joint
now the special actions that do happen
at the true ankle joint are a pair of
movements called
dorsiflexion and plantar flexion
dorsiflexion means pointing the toes
toward the ceiling like walking on your
heels
and this happens at the hinge joint of
the ankle
plantar flexion is the opposite movement
that points your toes downward toward
the floor like standing on your tiptoes
as i tell my students you dorsiflex your
ankle to move from the gas pedal to the
brake and then you plant or flex your
foot to press down on the brake pedal
the true ankle joint is a hinge joint
while it's a series of gliding joints
within the foot that allow the movements
of inversion and eversion
protraction and retraction are a set of
movement classifications that occur at a
limited number of joints
protraction means to protrude a body
part pushing it anteriorly
while retraction is the opposite pulling
that body part back to anatomical
position or pulling it in a posterior
direction
an example of this is seen at the
shoulders with the scapula or shoulder
blade and with the clavicles commonly
called collar bones
you protract your scapulae when you push
your shoulders forward and you retract
them when you pull them together
posteriorly
like when correcting poor posture
the joint where the jaw meets the rest
of the skull is another place where
protraction and retraction occur
protraction pushes the jaw forward
while retraction pulls it back into its
normal orientation
as we'll see the jaw joint where the
mandible connects to the rest of the
skull is a little more complicated it's
a gliding joint that allows protraction
retraction and even side to side gliding
movements but it's also a hinge joint
that's a lot that allows us to open and
close the mouth
which is called depression and elevation
of the mandible
like the joint at the jaw the scapulae
of the shoulder girdle can also elevate
and depress when you shrug your
shoulders you're elevating your scapulae
and the clavicles that connect to them
and then you can also depress the
shoulder girdle bringing the shoulders
down away from your ears
lastly let's consider the hand
remember the saddle joint i mentioned
between the thumb and one of the carpels
of the wrist
that allows a pretty remarkable ability
of primates like monkeys apes and humans
to oppose their thumb to their other
fingers
this makes for what is known as a
prehensile hand or grasping hand an
exceptional feature that is one of the
hallmarks of our species and which
enables our ability to make and use
tools
opposition is the term for that movement
of the thumb and reposition is the
opposite of opposition i couldn't resist
saying that just for fun
we'll talk about other thumb motions
when we cover the hand
in fact we will learn more about other
specific movements possible at a whole
variety of diarthrotic synovial joints
in the body
as we cover each body region we'll go
into the specific bony landmarks and
their shapes which allow particular
movements at a given joint and don't
allow others
we'll learn about the ligaments that
restrict movement in a given direction
and help stabilize the joint while still
facilitating movement
we'll also learn which joints have
articular discs and occasionally discuss
some of their bursi
and when we get to those specifics we'll
return to the terminology of movement we
used in this lesson and gain a deeper
understanding of the relationship
between structure and function
another thing we'll cover in future
lessons are various clinical
correlations that i hope will help us
better understand normal structure and
function
as well as illustrate the ways in which
trauma and pathology can negatively
affect our movement and our
musculoskeletal health
i hope it will also add interest to
consider dysfunction when we cover
specific bones joints muscles and nerves
it certainly seems to pique the interest
of my students
while we're on this topic i'd like to
add something interesting to think about
regarding joints
of all of the elements of the
musculoskeletal system
joints are the only components that are
readily and frequently replaced by
artificial substitutes known as
prosthetic joints
when a joint is worn out
a person might be a good candidate for
arthroplasty
that's the medical term for the surgical
installation of a prosthetic joint i bet
every one of us knows someone and likely
multiple people who have had joint
replacement surgery
recent estimates indicate that each year
in the u.s alone there are about 700 000
knee replacements and about 400 000
total hip replacements
one source suggests quote total joint
arthroplasty is one of the most cost
effective and successful interventions
in medicine
the history of joint replacement surgery
goes back to the 1800s in the united
states
but so-called total joint replacements
didn't begin until about this 1970s
now some of us may remember the tv
series from the 70s called the 6 million
dollar man
well we used to call my dad the bionic
man because of that show
dad had an autoimmune condition that
greatly affected his joints and range of
motion
so starting in the 1970s he began
getting a series of joint replacement
surgeries that spanned over 20 years
this even included a pair of prosthetic
wrist joints that were experimental at
the time and eventually had to be
removed
in those days there were many
limitations on how long the replacements
might last
and different body sizes and patients
weren't so easily accommodated
some of the early models were one size
fits all
since then rates of joint replacements
have grown steadily with many
refinements in styles durability and
success
these have given some of our family
members friends and perhaps even us
restored range of motion and a more
pain-free lifestyle
i recall my dad saying after his first
knee replacement some days everything on
me hurts except for my new knee
and dad also gained a great respect for
physical therapists and was thrilled
when i began teaching anatomy to them
this is because following arthroplasty
pts and other clinicians step in to
teach a patient how to safely return to
function using their artificial joint
including what movements they can and
should do to rehabilitate as well as
which motions the patient should avoid
especially while healing
of course that's not the only time
people participate in physical therapy
pts are experts in restoring range of
motion in all types of musculoskeletal
issues
in fact some of the basic practices of
physical therapists are actually called
range of motion activities
and might be employed long before a
joint replacement surgery or help stall
or even prevent the need for
arthroplasty
these can be broken down into subgroups
such as passive and active range of
motion exercises
so let's close by talking about a few of
these to reinforce some of the joint
movement terminology from this lesson
in passive range of motion exercises the
clinician moves a patient's body parts
when they cannot
whether the patient is immobile from
paralysis or other pathology
this hands-on therapy helps loosen stiff
joints relaxes tense connective tissues
and stretches muscles to guide them
hopefully back to normal function
but in active range of motion physical
therapy
the pt directs the patient to move their
body
even if simply starting in bed after
surgery
this might involve doing ankle pumps by
repeated dorsiflexion and plantar
flexion
or heel slides where the person keeps
their heel on the bed but then
alternates between flexion and extension
of the knee
moving up to the hip the therapist might
have the patient alternate between
abduction and adduction of the hip
joints by sliding a lower limb
laterally and then bringing it back
medially
by working from the feet to the knees
and then the hips
even a person who is bedridden can get
blood flow moving and keep their muscles
engaged
this will hopefully get the person back
on their feet faster and out of the
hospital quicker after an injury or
following surgery
i'm sure plenty of us have benefited
from physical therapy to improve range
of motion
or restore strength to an injured or
recovering body part
restoring or gaining range of motion
isn't limited to physical therapy of
course i'm sure many of us have
participated in yoga or general
stretching to improve the function of
our joints and build strength in our
muscles
so now let's move to our next lesson and
examine how muscles or their tendons
cross our joints and cause them to move